je vous propose aux rires ce journal
avec cette information médicale qui à
terme pourrait apporter une amélioration
considérable dans le traitement de la
stérilité et dans le celui de la
ménopause
une première mondiale celle d'une équipe
de médecins britanniques et américains
qui ont réussi à réimplanter à nos
verres ou plus exactement une partie
d'un tissu d'un ovaire sur une jeune
femme âgée d'une trentaine d'années une
prouesse technique à laquelle il faut
ajouter la détermination de la patiente
puisque c'est elle qui est partie via
internet à la recherche de spécialistes
capables peut-être de traiter la
stérilité jordan et illzach et marc
grodwohl date est entré dans l'histoire
de la médecine cette semaine
cette américaine de 30 ans qui a subi
l'ablation de ces deux ovaires vient de
bénéficier de la première greffe de
tissu ovarien grâce à ses propres
cellules
les chirurgiens avaient pensé à prélever
des fragments de tissus lors de
l'intervention et les avaient congé deux
ans plus tard la réimplantation a eu
lieu le vert à deux fonctions de la
puberté à la ménopause il libère un
ovule à chaque cycle par la même période
il sécrète des hormones estrogènes et
progestérone qui jouent un rôle
fondamental
ôtez les ovaires entraîne donc une
ménopause précoce et une stérilité
définitive la conservation des fragments
de verre se fait aussi en france
l'espoir est de pouvoir un jour aider
des femmes ayant eu à subir des
traitements très agressive pour divers
cancers à retrouver leur fertilité
ces prélèvements s'adresse à des
patientes qui vont avoir des traitement
stérilisant c'est à dire des traitements
à base de chimiothérapie et de
radiothérapie ou l'association signaux
radiothérapie ces traitements sont
effectués dans le cadre de maladies
cancéreuses mais peuvent être aussi
effectué dans le cadre d'autres
pathologies non cancéreuses mais pour
lesquels un traitement lourd est
nécessaire
quatre mois après la greffe les médecins
de margrethe ont annoncé qu'elle a eu
une ovulation que si un premier cycle
normal elle a donc déjà gagné en partie
son combat que dans et de saintes